let's poop in butth holes my name is Mt
and welcome back to the have a spoiler
show and Rick and Morty is back baby
season 7 starts off with Rick trying to
sooth a poopy butthole but not with
toilet paper but with something even
more powerful the power of friendship
also a naked Hugh Jackman which
scientists have said is equally as
powerful today I'm going to be breaking
down all the details you could have
missed in this Interstellar non-
intervention of an intervention of an
episode so let us dive into that poopy
butthole together my nerd babies I hope
I never say that
again and the episode starts off with PB
getting a special delivery from a street
pharmacist who definitely stays on her
business lady flow as she pretty much
immediately tries to offer Morty and
summer drugs to help them Focus
something that naturally upsets Beth
notice how space Beth doesn't react
whatsoever though very much reflecting
how much she could not give a damn about
what Morty and summer do as independent
people as she herself has very likely
done her fair share of pharmaceuticals
during her adventures throughout her
space because an infinite Cosmos means
me an infinite amount of drugs and you
know your dealer has a passion for what
they do if they sport a marijuana leaf
necklace like the dealer does here so
I'm not even sure why normal best is
hating on a small business owner trying
to live her best life while also helping
out her community but hate she does and
Beth's annoyance leads her to confront
PB in a living room that is not as tidy
as it usually is because our boy PBZ is
very much going through it right now in
the background you can see that PB has
thrown up in a nearby vase likely due to
all the beer and copyright proof Jack
Daniels that he's been drinking but he
also clearly has not been eating the
best either as his diet primarily
consists of half eaten pizza and burgers
from a knockoff brand McDonald's with
only one golden arch instead of two we
know that Mr Poopy butthole is a big fan
of pizza from the season 2 finale when
he freaks out a pizza delivery man
however when he's not eating and
drinking his sorrows away Mr Hull has
been strengthening his reading muscle by
reading custody law for dummies
undoubtedly a New York Times bestseller
and not only does this point to a
potentially nasty custody battle between
him and his ex-wife but it also acts as
a clever piece of foreshadowing to poopy
butts kidnapping poopy Jr later on in
the episode PB then tries to Guilt Trip
Beth by reminding her of the time that
she shot him at the end of season 2
episode 4's total rickall episode but
what's kind of weird here is that he
complains about having been riddled with
bullets when Beth technically shot him
with a plasma gun so there shouldn't
have been any bullets involved
whatsoever but then as the intro theme
plays we get what could be potential
looks at future episodes of the Season
including a summer inhan with super
strength lifting Rick off the ground
thanks to what appears to be a high-tech
bracelet that Rick makes for her then
Rick's being excited to see a zombie
hand rise from the grave after shoveling
the zombie out with Morty causing me to
wonder if this could be the Zombie
versions of the Rick and Morty that our
Rick and Morty replaced at the end of
season one episode 6 then we see Beth
and space Beth being forced to do a
Swiss folk dance for aliens as a Morty
and summer enjoy the benefits of alien
royalty a bigheaded Rick and Morty
snowboarding on their own tongues and
finally a reference to 1987's blood
Blood Sport AS Jerry does a split across
two chairs like jeanclaude vanam does in
that movie then the episode continues
where we left Rick off at the end of
season 6 obsessed with finding and
killing Rick Prime the Rick variant
responsible for the death of his native
universe's wife and child Diane and Beth
in that Quest you can see that Rick's
been analyzing his own DNA in order to
lock in on Rick Prime's potential
location after mysteriously finding out
at the very end of last season's finale
that Rick Prime was in multiple places
at once and later after Rick creates a
Robo ghost with long black hair just
like the evil spirit from the ring and
then messes up the gravity and floor
science of his creation you can
literally see Rick looking at an image
of Earth's gravitational field next to
an image of a floor as he tries to fix
those bugs I find it hilarious how
Rick's unfinished business ghost was
itself unfinished adding more genuine
anguish to that falling robot's
miserable existence this is the second
Rick and Mory episode in a row to deal
with a piece of technology that Rick
introduces falling through the floor as
the season 6 finale dealt with a robot
Rick giving Morty a lightsaber that ends
up falling vertically towards the
Earth's core also super random but I
find it hilarious how the clock in
Rick's garage has pretty much always
been stuck at 2:00 since the start of
the series as it shows that Rick truly
doesn't care about repairing the little
things right in front of him that need
repairing kind of like his entire
relationship with his family in the
current season as Rick's obsession with
avenging his family is robbing him of
time with the family making memories
together upstairs he's too focused on
the past and making futuristic
Technologies to notice what's going on
in the present but anyways after the
family threatens Rick with an
intervention if he doesn't give Mr poops
an intervention Rick goes to collect the
homies first of which is the gear themed
alien Man by the name of Rolio clockberg
Jr a man who Rick refers to as Gearhead
a term that Gearhead tells Rick that he
considers a racial slur in season 2
episode 2 right before Rick shoves his
gear junk into his gear mouth for
selling him and Moria to the Gear police
Gearhead would of course get his gear
junk shoved into his mouth again by the
the Predator later on in this episode
but anyways when Gearhead answers the
door for Rick you can see a gear themed
pinup model leaning against a race car
on a poster that says rack and pinions
which is very much something a person
named Gearhead would have in their home
as a Gearhead is of course a term for
someone who is adept at fixing cars and
vehicles like Gearhead is in the series
Rick only convinces Gearhead to join him
by telling him that Gearhead owes him
calling back to the time when Gearhead
betrayed him and I love how when they
get to squash's house his house is just
a chaotic mess of cat tunnels and empty
beer cans because that pretty much sums
up this alcoholic party cat pretty damn
well and bird daughter isn't really one
for tidiness either as her rebellious
phase has led her to leave all of her
bird all over bird person's living
room the spitting image of her evil
mother Tammy bird daughter is of course
making her second appearance after the
post-credit scene of season 5 episode 8
revealed her to have been held in a
Galactic Federation prison ever since
she was a small bird child a time that
bird daughter references when she tells
her dad that living with him is worth
than living in prison which is saying a
lot considering that her time in prison
has left her with an intense hatred for
the Galactic Federation itself with bird
person even chastising her for leaving a
gromflomite femur in the compost as well
as for having a bloody hit list for the
members of the Federation that wronged
her with the GRL minds of course being
the alien species who held her in
captivity you can see that before bird
person walked in bird daughter was
reading a magazine called beak talk
while texting on her iPhone themed after
a bird egg then when Squan and Gearhead
wave at bird person when Rick invites
him to the Gathering Gearhead appears to
be drinking a gear themed beer while
sany and Rick drink actual alcohol
possibly implying that his drink might
have some motor oil in it or something
to lube up his gears and after they
trigger a mini lawnmower Massacre when
Rick picks up his neighbor Jean the gang
head on over to Fu's bar which is a
parody of real life rude restaurants
where the staff is mean to you on
purpose you know just like Dick's Last
Resort or any McDonald's in the hood and
this restaurant is littered with rude
signage like the first is free at
the top of this Frame you puke we laugh
on the right over here and my personal
favorite no black light allowed a sign
that makes me question what happens at
this establishment after hours I'm also
a big fan of the copyright proof beer
sign in the corner background because I
just like things that smash the fourth
wall and then when Mr Poopy butthole
reveals to the gang that he's hired one
of the Predators from the Predator films
to stalk his wife he whips out his phone
to reveal that the Predator has a geoc
city's Business website that hasn't been
updated since 2001 which is a massive
Blast for the past and if you don't know
what a geoc C's website is
congratulations uh you didn't grow up
with dialup internet and that was the
worst and I really love how this website
has a little Sherlock Holmes hat and
magnifying glass to show that he is
truly a professional private
investigator and after that the boys
decide to go on a booa paloa with Jean
accidentally sucking the liquid out of
the wrong hole of an alien stripper a
very very wrong hole a hole that would
usually get you sent to prison right
away I am not exactly sure how Jean
messed up so badly when there are
clearly only five shots poured out but
you know something tells me that Jean
might not be the most familiar with
genitalia outside of his own but after
they hit a number of party spots the
gang eventually finds their way to a
honey Rave with people dressed up as
bumblebees a scene reminiscent to The
Blood Rave at the beginning of the first
blade movie someone on the Rick and
Morty staff really must like blade as
that movie was already referenced two
episodes ago in episode 9 season 6 when
Robo Rick gives Morty a sword programmed
with olive blades fight moves hell yeah
see that that's from when he's fighting
Deacon Frost
I don't know I thought it was cool but
soon at that very same honey Rave the
poopy party would eventually run into
Australian National Treasure Hugh
Jackman voiced by Australian National
Treasure Hugh Jackman who is apparently
related to Jean through Jean's cousin
which I guess makes Deborah Lee furnace
canonically Jean's cousin like it
generally makes me so sad to hear that
both Hugh and Deborah are separating in
real life after 27 years of marriage
though those two were always so
wholesome together Hugh Jackman then
invites the gang to party but emphasizes
that they party as a team a definite nod
to his team leader role as Wolverine in
the X-Men movies but before they leave
Hugh tells the group that he has to
leave to take a huge Aman and that Aman
is Australian slang for and that
they shouldn't look it up well after
looking it up I could not find that it
meant anything to do with feces but I
did find that Urban Dictionary defines
an acan as a synonym for a human penis
which who Jackman proves that he also
has by the end of the episode when his
acmen is exposed in the woods but
anyways when the scene switches to the
boy partying at the Jack Shack a poster
for the Jackman can be seen with you
Jackman in the roles of Wolverine Jean
Gray Beast Cyclops storm and Professor X
all at once and hanging right next to
that is a parody of the Le Miser robs
poster for a movie called Le Jackman
with Hugh Jackman in the role of coet
and later when Hugh Jackman starts to
have a heart-to- heart with Mr Poopy
butthole he tells the man in the top hat
that he originally wrote Billy Ocean's
1984 hit Caribbean Queen a song that
Hugh Jackman performs outside of Amy's
house a little bit B later with Jean
holding a boom box over his head like
John cusac in the 1989 movie say
anything but before that Mr Poopy
butthole asks Q Jackman if wolverin
hurts a little with everybody replying
with every time a throwback to
Wolverine's response to Rogue when he
asked him that in the first X-Men film
when they come
out does it
hurt every time but when the gang are
forced to flee from the Predator after
poopy senior steals poopy Jr they all
cover themselves and mud to hide
themselves from the Predator like Arnold
tegger did in Predator 1 and when Mr
Poopy butthole goes head-to-head with
The Predator he references season 4
episode 3 which is the heist episode one
crew over the crew's Morty where
Professor poopy butthole uses his
martial arts skills to send a bunch of
his students to the hospital causing him
to lose his job and his family as a
consequence so Rick truly is to blame
for the shittiness of pb's life right
now so I don't know why he was
complaining about this intervention cuz
like this was his fault but after things
chill out in the forest and Amy comes on
to the scene she reveals that pb's
chrisan name is actually Wayne poopy
butthole which kind of makes you wonder
why he thinks that this last name is
more refined because uh it's probably
why he can't get a job but soon after
Hugh Jackman would hit the Predator over
the head with a Grammy award that he won
for actually writing Billy Ocean's
Caribbean Queen which Rick is genuinely
confused at and looks at suspiciously
possibly even questioning whether or not
he truly knows the type of universe he's
in or maybe how different this universe
can be from his actual a native Universe
where Hugh Jackman never did that but
chances are it's probably just a funny
throwaway joke not meant to be taken
seriously and then finally the gang ends
the episode by chilling out in front of
a restaurant called Taco tambourine
whose logo is literally a mish mash of a
taco and a tambourine instrument and
before everyone heads their separate
ways I love how Hugh Jackman calls Mr
Poopy butthole a mutant considering his
history with playing the mutant
Wolverine and how Rick says here I go
peing again as a call back to when the
grite cmis Michael says oh boy here I go
killing again in season 2 episode 2 oh
boy here I go killing again and during
the post credit scene featuring a
sheriff seemingly designed after actor
Sam Elliot we catch up with the
murderous Rampage of Jean's Rogue La
Mower and right before that murder mower
claims its last victim the superstitious
Sheriff kisses a Christian cross a
picture of his granddaughter a shamrock
necklace and a Bible necklace before
singing an Irish classic called the
hills of dagal so needless to say the
bloody remains of this Sheriff have
definitely got some Irish Roots but
anyways thank you guys so much for
watching this breakdown of the season 7
premiere of Rick and Morty leave a
thumbs up if you liked it it always
helps out the channel you can follow me
at mastertainment on Twitter Instagram
or wherever I am on the social medias
but most importantly do not forget to
follow heavy spoilers here on YouTube
because we're always uploading fun stuff
and you don't want to miss out but
anyways thanks again for watching and
I'll see you guys later goodbye